ciao amici ciao mi bem
[Musica]
ciao ragazzi non so se si è visto che ho
pubblicato un libro è nata e una
libreria finta però non sembra cese
riduco la webcam in piccolo questa
settimana sono andato al salone del
libro che una fiera che si tiene a
torino da da un sacco di anni per
presentare appunto the cage che il mio
libro che tratto sta andando benissimo
di niente sono andato a presentare the
cage al salone del libro è stato un
successo anche lì e ho invitato la mia
prof d'italiano
sul palco del salone del libro vi lascia
video buona visione
[Musica]
siccome siamo al salone del libro ma non
sappiamo se arrivare al nostro
padiglione sarà tranquillo o meno
vedrete in questo video se la situazione
è degenerata perché ci siamo sempre
entrare nella bocca edizione di una
vacca che cade incredibile resistenza
mi piace un sacco di piace con il
merchandising miti leggende
[Applauso]
abbiamo ovviamente discusso di quanto io
fossi bravo a scuola di quanto tutti i
miei dieci forse ma come si diceva
fossero falsi ero molto bravo io a
scuola
[Musica]
[Applauso]
se alla fine anno ha mai sentito natale
noi volevamo andare a casa abbiamo
beccato la coda del tipo l'esodo di
ferragosto in questo punto ho iniziato a
bloccare ci stiamo muovendo ma vi giuro
che siamo qua dice uno che fa il pic nic
di cuore salerno reggio calabria dai
ragazzi non so cosa succede ai partiti
siamo fermi immobili qua c a juve milan
qua qua ma cerco perché stando tutti
perche io faccio il milan va bene va
bene per niente stiamo cercando di
andare a casa non ci arriveremo mai vi
aggiorno se inseriamo vivi per adesso
bella e meno male che ci sei tu
[Musica]
poverino è rosa mela tu non stai
guidando per guidare ax max guida
adesso ti immagini stato di immagine
cesari esatto non sono un bravo dai
proviamo non sono bravo a fare queste
cose su youtube guida ci provo ci provo
beh normale ax non male anche se siamo
fermi è in corso una partita memorabile
doveva devi masticare
berna il granello pagata 10 euro
l'ettaro caramello salato ma fa
veramente vomitare ma vi dò fastidio
fate deve sputare no non vengo quella
stoffa c'è nel nord
ma davvero devi buttare via
che schifo il portiere bravo chi è rosso
[Applauso]
e chi siamo e possiamo e anche i quali
multi bello
come la persona reale il bello allora
ecco quando a londra agli studiosi eric
holder che sono strategiche sono anch'io
è affatto questo facciamola reaction
bellissimo stai guardando il boccino
addirittura saluta che spavaldo sé
[Musica]
ma non ci avevi paura di lavoro a parte
il passaporto di arrivato questo che ci
andiamo in america con questo o con
quello puoi entrare in tutto il mondo
vabbè ma c'è il passaporto di harry
potter esiste io questo quasi
l'opportuna manifestazione alle tre
vieni con me nella mia meglio porti
questo dai pensa sia giusta
frank al tipo di apporto ma cosa sta
facendo che beckett e facendo l'anci si
poi c'è chi non farti a cercare dal sole
lo riprende il giura è difficilissimo mi
faccio vedere
viene bene era il tuo sport 3 di offrire
ma non comprate il merchandising fa vj
non solo le magliette che usciranno tra
ma anche gli zaini perché è ma non
possiamo far vedere sta roba e lanna e
l'anno prossimo
questo lo zaino dell'anno prossimo
ragazzi quel non possiamo farlo vedere
ma ve lo facciamo vedere ma l'anno
prossimo quando ne frega degli accordi
legali che abbiamo io ve lo faccio
vedere questo lo zaino dell'anno
prossimo di fa vj che puoi cambiare da
top anche lo strappi e ci sono le toppe
c'è rosa c'è azzurro c'è nero lo menti
qua e pam e chiara ferragni chimini
ragazzi che sei stata la mia giornata ho
cambiato tipo 800 vestiti in una
giornata sola non so se ve ne siete
accorti ma va bè ragazzi se non avete
the cage prendetelo perché è il nuovo
harry potter conca parte gli scherzi
davvero grazie giuro veramente grassi di
cuore per tutto il supporto per del
chigi perché è veramente non pensavo
andasse bene ed io non vedevo perché
dovesse andare male ma non così bene c'è
veramente uno stream mai aspettato
probabilmente tra un po verrà tradotto
anche in spagnolo in inglese in tedesco
in giapponese per essere worldwide però
non lo traduco io perché sennò sarebbe
pieno di sci io spero che vi sia
piaciuto video ragazzi con se vi è
piaciuto
mi piace una riflessione d'iscrizione se
non siete iscritti iscrivetevi ci
vediamo al prossimo video da ragazzi
nel video non ci sono parolacce perché
sono quasi sicuro che la mia prof andrà
a guardarlo quindi prof
visto che sono un bravo ragazzo che
utilizzano il linguaggio appropriato 10
[Musica]